[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
what's going on welcome back to the best
business show this is the best show
because we said it is
we are super excited we've got a massive
show today we've got massive giveaways
we are bringing the energy on a friday
i'm here with joe and john my brothers
how do you know their names are joe and
john real simple their names are on the
back of their chairs joe's a little
confused oh john with the arms you know
we're bringing friday energy summer
fridays is always friday in miami we
today have a great show for you we have
will clemente coming on we're gonna talk
about bitcoin on chain metrics we also
have jeff lewis the vibe capitalist
himself don't call him a venture
capitalist he's a vibe capitalist he's
gonna end the week with a vibe it's
gonna be pretty damn good you know the
drill today big big giveaways we're
gonna do two different giveaways first
we are going to pick one person from the
chat and we are gonna buy you two
tickets to an nfl game this weekend
that's right we're gonna pick somebody
in the chat later in the show we're
gonna let you tell us where is the local
game for you we're gonna buy you two
tickets and we're gonna send somebody to
an nfl game this weekend don't say we've
never done anything nice for you they're
supposed to take whoever they want they
take where they can take your mom your
girlfriend your dog your neighbor your
cousin's brother sister's dog whoever
you want you can take them no problem
that's the only reason why i asked i
wanted to hear you say brother sisters
brother sister mother cousin dog
neighbor stranger whatever you take
whoever you want but what we ask of you
is we need you to make sure that you are
smashing the like button the show is
free but the only thing we ask is you
keep hitting that like button when we
hit 500 likes we'll go ahead we'll give
away nfl tickets on top of that
if we get to what do we what's the
number that we have to get to today
what's the big goal because we got a big
giveaway i'm gonna give away a thousand
dollars of bitcoin to one person to go
into the weekend 2500 likes 2 500 likes
all right 500 likes somebody gets nfl
tickets 2 500 likes i'll give away a
thousand dollars with a bitcoin you know
how the show starts so
get on your group chat get on twitter
get on instagram dm text your side chick
text your girlfriend your mom your
sister your neighbor your cousin your
brother your dog whoever you want tell
them to come watch the show and make
sure they're hitting that like button
let's get after it hey this is one of
the giveaways where if you win nfl
tickets you can say dude like thanks for
your entry fee take me let's go
true yeah that is true team up on that
say listen we try to go to the game this
weekend all right we got a whole bunch
of stuff to get into but before we get
into anything
you know what time it is it's friday
there's only one person who joins us on
fridays mufasa
time to get the energy going let's go
[Music]
look at them
dance moves that will never go out of
style
[Music]
[Music]
is it coming is he going to do it block
it out walk it out
every time i see this video i think if
this was first taken all right
had to be
man what
what a move there we go a little spin
move to get it going all right so we got
mufasa ready to rock and roll
trillionaire energy today make sure you
keep smashing the like button we hit 500
likes we will give away two nfl tickets
to a game this weekend by the way uh
mike
maladano we already got people talking
nonsense he's talking [ __ ] in the chat
he's like are they going to be nosebleed
seats or feel you think we're going to
put you in the nosebleeds come on man if
john was picking you up now but now if
mike wins you're getting nosebleeds
out of here come on we're not putting
anyone in the nose please we're gonna
send you right so you can see the game
real nice we expect a photo maybe a
little selfie action at the game we'll
pull it up on the show on monday let's
get after it there's only show in the
world where you come you learn and you
get free stuff so make sure you keep
smashing the like button showing up
every single day
we have talked about it non-stop on this
show economists are no better than
casino gamblers
we just got the non-farm payroll numbers
the estimate was that we were going to
get
500
000 new jobs
we got under 200 000.
less than 50 percent
what is going on the u.s labor september
non-farm payroll the consensus
the entire market had agreed on the
estimate of 500 000
it came in under 200 000
you literally could put a blindfold on
spin around and throw darts and probably
be more accurate than these people
that is absurd if you went to work every
day and you are off by more than 50
percent month after month after month
after month after month
after month after month after month
eventually you would be fired
it is unacceptable that we have economic
estimates that are this far off if you
say hey every once in a while we're off
by 10 i get it it's a complex economic
system there's tons of variables there's
tons of inputs that drive these numbers
but to miss this bad and have us talk
about it month after month after month
is a joke
we should either stop estimating
or
we should start to see what the
repercussions are because there are
financial decisions being made on the
estimates some people are buying assets
some of them are selling assets some of
them are waiting for the numbers and
trading and the people who end up being
the least effective trading around these
numbers are those that are the least
sophisticated the retail traders so if
we are going to have estimates and they
continue to be this far off you at home
have to realize it's never going to
change they're going to continue to
estimate inaccurately i wish that there
was a way to bet on whether they had an
accurate estimate or not
if there was a way to bet on every
non-farm payroll day or the release of
the numbers and i could simply say i
think they got it right or i think they
didn't i don't even need to know the
numbers i'm betting they didn't get it
right and i'd be a very very very rich
person because you could literally bet
the house every time that's how absurd
their inaccuracy is but we continue to
play this charade nobody's calling out
the nonsense nobody says
wait why are they off by more than 50
percent
how is that possible well it's because
when you look at bad data and you have
astrology like models that literally
just make things up you just come up
with made-up numbers like 500 000 and
then real number comes in at 194k
if you
were taking a test in school
and you were off by that much you would
get an f
fail
they would literally say if you get this
score on every test
you don't get credit for the class you
failed it's an f
and so at some point we have to ask
ourselves how much of monetary and
fiscal policy is being driven by the
data and the analysis of the same exact
people that are this inaccurate if we
have bad data
there's no way we can make good
decisions you need good data to make
good decisions but what we've seen time
and time again
is just a whiff
this is pathetic in my opinion
right
yeah i mean look we're way off but i
think the other thing to note is that
we're way down from last month right so
growth is
supposed to be accelerating at this
point job growth as we get out of the
pandemic and as we return to normal and
do all these things it's slowing down
it's stalling right and you have some
economist online and on on twitter
saying oh it's seasonal now they're
calling it seasonal they're saying the
government employees uh their jobs are
seasonal and we shouldn't have added as
many because of that stop with the
transitory the seasonal stop with the
words uh to cover up that you're wrong
right so uh
they've been wrong about these estimates
time and time again last month i think
yeah we were at uh 366k jobs added last
month after revisions this month we're
at 194 on an estimate of 500 so we've
stalled dramatically and if you look at
kind of the whole of where we're
supposed to be on an expected job basis
based on kind of just current growth
trends we're still about 9 million jobs
in the hole and that if you look on it
kind of compared to the rest of history
that's about where we were at the bottom
at the bottom pit of the 08 recession
right so like it's really really really
bad and it's not getting any better
we're not going to get anywhere near
close to that 9 million jobs number
anytime soon based on the growth already
stalling kind of when we're supposed to
be exiting the pandemic on top of that
there's 11 million open jobs in the
economy world record number of open
rolls it's not a demand or um it's not a
supply problem there's literally 11
million open jobs at the moment
it just exploded look at the growth of
open rolls right after the pandemic and
now all of a sudden we're saying oh but
we can't get people to go back to work
if there's this many open roles
and there's only 194 000 people going
back to work and we're seeing a slowdown
there's no tapering coming
there's no sort of slowdown in the
economic stimulus
the only thing that central banks can do
is they can manipulate the interest
rates or they can provide more liquidity
to the market through things like
quantitative easing and if you have the
economic slowdown from a job growth
standpoint and you have this many open
roles you still have over five percent
unemployment and you have cpi'd over
five percent in core inflation over four
percent this is a disaster
this is an absolute disaster that we
have on our hands on top of that more
people have died of covet in 2021 than
in 2020.
so not only are we not addressing the
public health crisis
but also we're not addressing the
economic crisis either
so what is going on
and i don't see anyone coming out and
saying here's the plan here's how we're
going to address the issues here is the
light at the end of the tunnel instead
what you're seeing is more and more and
more people are actually losing hope and
ultimately that's the problem is when
people lose hope they give up on
searching for a job they actually just
relegate themselves to a life
of just despair and dire financial
situation that's not the way it should
be we live in the most prosperous most
democratic most capitalistic society in
the world we should not have these
problems you should not go talk to
business owners and say
how is it and then say i literally can't
get people to come work at my business
and then go talk to other people and
they say we have the high unemployment
rate of over five percent right now
what's going on
i don't think that anyone has the
answers but what i do know is that we
can't continue to have interventions in
the market because the more that you
take away those free market forces you
get nonsense like this this is a
manipulated economy it's a manipulated
asset prices it's manipulated monetary
and fiscal policy and so what do we get
we get
an economy that makes zero sense right
john
yeah i mean
missing that much is is big uh i'm
starting to think that every time they
do expectations just take the under if
it was kind of an over under i would go
under every single time um 11 minutes
it's inflation
11 million jobs is absolutely insane
it's almost becoming the normal right we
saw 10.1
10 10 around 10 million jobs then we
went to 11 million jobs and i expect
both the number of open rolls and the
number of non-farm payrolls to increase
in the coming months as we get to that
non like seasonal adjusted with um with
the holiday season coming up a lot more
people are ramping up i think 10 of jobs
that are currently available for
seasonal workers for the holiday season
are considered urgent so
people they're gonna find workers but
the number of workers obviously has
significantly decreased and to your
point about as we get more into like hey
if i've been have a job for six months
eight months it almost becomes a new
normal where you stop looking as hard as
you did in that first month right and
then over time it's just like man i'm
not going to be able to find the job
someone said that we should come up with
our own projections each month boys
motors did it last month and was closer
ready
here's my projection for jobs for
october i need to look at zero data zero
data 275 000 non-payroll uh non-farm
payroll 275 book and keep the receipt
we'll see it october numbers my guess is
we're closer than the economist i
literally just came up with a number off
top of my head said 275 275 yeah that's
a good guess i'm on board with that 275.
hey economist guess what you suck you're
going to be more wrong than me that's
how this works it's just they're going
to go crunch a bunch of numbers they're
going to have their little uh pen
protectors in their little pocket or
whatever they're going to go out there
they're going to have all their
calculators they're going to do all
their computations they're going to go
scour the world for all this data and
they're still going to miss by 50
so i just came up with 275 000 it cost
me zero dollars i didn't need to employ
anybody and i'm probably just as wrong
as they are
yeah i love how like 50 has become like
acceptable like no one even questions it
anymore they're just like uh whatever
yeah 50 wrong it's okay i love every
single person that works with us
right if somebody kept being off by
fifty percent i would immediately fire
them every month
one job per month you're supposed to
come up with all these guys we gotta
transition you into a different role or
we gotta find you another job
imagine if every day i was like hey joe
uh what do you think today uh x is gonna
happen and you were wrong every day
eventually i would either stop asking
you
right or two i would start asking you
knowing that you were gonna be wrong and
trade the other way and that's
essentially what's happening here is
they're they're just
in here's the worst part is i actually
think they're trying to do the best they
can but all of the methodology is
garbage yeah just the way they count is
garbage the way they get the data is
garbage the way they analyze the data is
garbage it's all garbage so when you put
data that is inaccurate and not fully uh
represent representative of the entire
uh uh kind of economy and then you have
bad analysis you get bad outcomes what i
mean it's obvious that's what's going on
it's just it's uh the the thing that
annoys me too is like as much as i love
that the videos of the alligator getting
trapped in the trash can and stuff like
we need to be talking about this stuff
i mean like those videos are great leave
that for social media to kind of find
and send out but this is the stuff we
should be talking about right and not oh
equities went up 0.05 today like no one
gives a crap right like this is the
important stuff how much money the
government's printing what's happening
with inflation investments yeah sure but
we don't need to track uh you know uh gm
and ford stock every day in the in the
0.1 movement that it's doing that's all
you see when you go on these these news
sites they're they're basically trying
to tell you oh this is what we think is
going to happen in the stock market and
they're also wrong yeah well it's just
much bigger uh trends are happening with
kind of the stuff going on in government
in the federal reserve uh and it doesn't
seem like it's talked about frankly
nearly enough
all right ready we got 500 likes by the
way
i wanted to say that's because i'm a
noted good guy i want to let everyone
know we crossed the line john's about to
pick a winner who are we picking john
what's up the question on the count of
three hold on on the count of three i
want everyone to smash the like button
one behind two like three hit the like
button yeah we're way behind i don't
know what you all are doing people
watching 600 likes let's go i don't know
what's going on there it's free this is
a free show the only thing you got to do
is you got to hit the like button let's
go all right
john is going to pick one person right
now in the chat to give tickets
for an nfl game this weekend let's make
them tell us
what game they're going to yeah what
game will you build would you like to be
taking and who are you taking what game
do you want to go to and who are you
taking we're going to pick one person
right now we're going to buy two tickets
to that nfl game and we will send you
and a friend your mom your brother your
sister your dad your dog your aunt your
uncle your neighbor or a stranger
whoever did you say side chick earlier
by the way yes
that just kind of went under the radar
that was pretty absurd though
just say somebody said that all right so
john's gonna pick one person right now
that we're gonna send to an nfl game
this weekend the only ask that we have
for you outside of going ahead and uh uh
going to the game with a friend is that
we need a photo you need to send us a
photo so we can pull it up on the other
side and please and and before you
comment please make sure that you know
where the team is playing this weekend
whether it's home or away because i've
been feeling a lot of people are just
throwing out their team in the comments
and they don't know if it's home or away
yet so we're not flying into the game
all right we've got to be in the city
you got to be in the town and i guess
worst comes the worst if it is next
weekend we can figure that out yeah yeah
that's fine all right john who do you
got for us you got a winner
um yeah i do
yanni uh pistachis how do you spell it
y-i-a-n-n-i
and then b-i-s i know why john victim
why
his answer was giants game my mom wants
to go my name is john in greek
i got you
[Laughter]
john you guys john might be removed from
all duties of big and people what's
wrong with that that's like a soft form
of corruption right there or some sort
of influence people are making me feel
good makes them feel good
there's nothing wrong with that
congratulations i respected it
unbelievable all right there we go uh he
said yes i love you bro
good vibes goodbye all right drop your
twitter you got to drop your twitter
account in there right now uh yanni so
that uh uh john can go ahead and message
you we're gonna get you two tickets to
the giants were they playing at the
cowboys at cowboys at the couch where do
you live let us know where you live you
better go and download jerry's world
going to jerry's world
all right so gonna go hang out at
jerry's world watch
with what did he say his mom his mom
he's bringing his mom shawn in greek
that's really why i picked them up
i know of wait because of his mom or
because of john in greek because he's
picking his mom he's bringing his mother
that's a nice guy nice guy not a good
guy bringing his mom all right all right
we're gonna call him greek john i see
naomi saying greek john's we got greek
john we got american john uh teaming up
with each other here we're gonna go
ahead we're gonna uh buy you two
uh two tickets to the giants cowboys
game this weekend you bring your mom we
want a ticket
we gotta fly him here from greece
okay fine whatever um all right pretty
awesome uh that uh that we're gonna do
that john i appreciate you uh you
picking somebody there now here's the
big ask when we get to 2.5 k likes we
got work to do here when we get to 2.5 k
likes we're gonna give away a thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin if we don't get
there i'm not giving away the bitcoin a
thousand dollars of bitcoin to one
person in the chat going into the
weekend if we get to 2.5 k likes so
let's get after it start hitting the
like button go tell your friends your
mom your dad your aunt your uncle your
cousin your dog your neighbor your
stranger whoever go get them tell them
to come watch the show send them the
link and let's go all right 14 of
americans now own bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies bank of america has
released a new 140 page report covering
digital asset industry including nfts
institute institutional investments and
the rates of growth it's called the
global cryptocurrencies in digital
assets reports digital asset primer in
brief only the first inning they've got
enough authors on here to fill out an
entire baseball team but by the numbers
it's estimated that 21.2 million u.s
adults own digital assets about 14
of us adults own digital assets they
believe that another 13
plan to buy in 2021 that would bring us
to a total of 27 percent of the united
states population will use our own
cryptocurrencies before the end of the
year
now on top of that they say that there
are over 200 million crypto users
globally there are now 11 500 plus
altcoins or tokens outside of bitcoin
although many do not have a clear use
case they are incredibly bullish in this
report they say we are only in the first
innings of a major change in
applications across most industries that
will take place over the next 30 years
so kind of a multi-decade outlook here
from bank of america the estimates
indicate that 221 million users globally
as of june 2021 had traded a
cryptocurrency or used a blockchain
based application which is up from 66
million at the end of may 2020. and then
also the second point is that due to
technological advances in decentralized
software that is native to the internet
a new medium with distributed ledgers
and blockchains at its core it is
emerging rapidly and so when we think
about this 14 as of june
of u.s population own cryptocurrency but
they believe that that will jump all the
way up to 27 of us adults will own
cryptocurrencies before the end of the
year that is a big number but not very
surprising when you start to look at the
numbers like a coin base which has over
55 million registered users the bigger
number to me and the more surprising
numbers that they estimate now over 220
million people globally own crypto
assets or have used blockchain based
applications that seems like a really
really big number and so when you see a
large organization like a bank of
america going out and putting in a ton
of work creating a report like this and
releasing it and being ultra bullish you
have to think that over the next couple
of decades we are likely to see a
drastic increase in the adoption of
these assets more participation from the
legacy system and also if you see an
increase in adoption and an increase in
institutional participation it will
likely lead to prices of various assets
and various technologies continuing to
appreciate for years to come what was
the most surprising part of this report
to you john
um the fact that they said 14 use it now
i wasn't surprised by that number i was
surprised that they said this report was
released earlier this week that 13
more people will hold digital assets uh
u.s adults will hold digital assets by
the end of the year basically right they
the report said in 2021. so it was a
little bit surprising to me that within
a three-month span or whenever they
started working on this report that we
are actually gonna double the amount of
people of us adults that hold digital
assets that was the most surprising and
obviously bank of america is very
bullish on bitcoin and very bullish on
cryptocurrency
joe what do you think
yeah i think uh what's surprising me is
kind of what's been happening over the
last week or so right when you look at
uh bitcoin has traditionally
moved alongside other risk assets right
when you look at kind of the the four
five six seven year history here uh
there's obviously been some booms cycles
some bull markets and bear markets et
cetera and it hasn't been kind of a
perfect outlet but especially over the
last couple years it's it's been moving
alongside traditional risk assets assets
and over the last one to two weeks it's
really decoupled from that right so if
you look at everything that's happening
in the equity markets and kind of the
other markets uh in finance bitcoin is
moving outside of that so we have a
bunch of uh jobs aren't growing as fast
the unemployment rate is high inflation
is bad uh you know all these things that
there's regulatory uncertainty covet is
stalling and people aren't going back to
work all this stuff right has put equity
markets in kind of a standstill over the
last few weeks bitcoin's up 25 this
month we're what we're eight days in
right so when you look at it kind of
it's out performance it's done really
well over the last month and then i
think if you look at it from kind of
the adoption that we're seeing
it's obvious that 2017 uh 2020 and going
forward it's not just kind of fear or
fomo or people trying to get rich or
people trying to uh realize profits all
this stuff and chasing all that
there's real adoption uh that's
happening both in the institutional
world and the retail world countries
have it as legal tender there's a bunch
of other stuff going on but i think the
main thing to realize is that like this
isn't going anywhere right like the
saying i believe is just bitcoin is
inevitable and when you look at it from
kind of the adoption numbers that legacy
banks are now putting out and all these
other institutions are saying hey look
this is going to grow by a lot over the
next short time period but also over the
long run a bunch of people are going to
adopt these assets a bunch of people are
going to hold them personally i think
what we're going to see is that massive
price appreciation continue and i
wouldn't be surprised if uh if we get
further and further away and decouple
ourselves further from traditional risk
assets like equities
john what do you think about that at
what point in time do you think that we
get
more uncorrelated with the other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin in general
and then um equities as well i think the
decoupling is only going to continue for
for quite a while here but it all feeds
together right if you think about if you
zoom out for a second here is like the
the um uh here's like the macro view of
what's happening in the world right now
you have technology as a deflationary
force part of the reason why there's 11
million open jobs there's high
unemployment et cetera is because
technology is driving the cost of labor
down drastically it's actually allowing
businesses to do more with less human
labor right so you have this massive
technology force that drive down
deflation on top of that you have
politicians who now are essentially the
drivers of fiscal monetary policy when
they tell people to jump they jump and
so what they're incentivized to do is
mitigate short-term pain if all of a
sudden we are going through a transition
from lots of human labor needed to do
tasks to now replacing that with
technology you then have humans that are
displaced from their jobs that
short-term pain politicians will not
allow to occur because it's bad for
business it doesn't get you re-elected
if your people are suffering so what
they do then is they use both their
direct powers and indirect influence to
get the treasury the federal reserve and
other organizations to go ahead and
participate in the devaluation of the
currency the entire idea is we can
basically borrow a bunch of debt which
is a complete ponzi scheme in terms of
borrowing more debt to pay off earlier
debt then on top of that what we can do
is we can continue to devalue that
currency we will hand out direct
stimulus we'll manipulate interest rates
we'll do everything we can to keep
kicking the can down the road but what
ultimately occurs is that while it feels
good in the short term to give somebody
money a 1200 stimulus check it actually
hurts them over the next 18 36 or five
months or five years because what they
really start to see is then they get
high inflation so right now if you look
over the last 18 months what happened
was there was a public health crisis it
drove economic slowdown that economic
slowdown led to short-term pain
short-term pain was addressed by
politicians and central bankers they
stepped in they intervened to the market
manipulated interest rates down to zero
they printed trillions of dollars they
handed some of that money directly to
people they also handed it directly to
corporations and they also stuffed it in
every corner of the complex financial
system when they did that it felt good
i'm getting a 1200 check i'm getting a
boost to unemployment etc but now all of
a sudden the bottom 45 percent of
americans that hold no assets and didn't
participate in the insane asset
appreciation that occurred by owning a
house by having some sort of stock
portfolio crypto portfolio etc those
individuals also happen to be the people
who buy the most amount of inflationary
goods their groceries is a very large
percentage let's say of their actual
monthly spending and so they're the ones
who get hurt the worst by the inflation
that is now here so if you're in the
bottom forty-five percent of a marriage
it's about 150 plus million americans
what ends up happening is that you
literally got the public health crisis
then you got the economic slowdown then
you got handed money but that money
ended up actually being a net negative
over the long term because now you're
dealing with insane levels of rent of
grocery prices other assets going up etc
and so now as you start to try to
operate your life what you're realizing
is wait a second the politicians who are
mitigating the short-term pain did it at
the expense of the medium to long term
and so we get in a situation where what
can i do with my wealth well i can't
hold dollars i can't buy treasuries i
can go buy stocks maybe there's some
commodities i can buy or i can buy
crypto currencies but if i know that the
stock market is susceptible to the same
exact manipulation the second that they
say ah you know what we're going to
taper the stock market's going to crater
so okay i don't want to maybe
participate in the same thing i'm going
to seek out uncorrelated assets where's
the uncorrelated assets well treasury
stocks et cetera they all move together
the most uncorrelated asset or the most
attractive uncorrelated asset from a
risk return standpoint is bitcoin it's
got a 0.15 percent correlation level
this sharp ratio is off the chart it's
returned over 400 percent of the last 12
months and if you can actually stomach
the volatility in the short term and
hold for a long period of time it's been
the single greatest performing asset
over the last decade so you start to say
to yourself okay well maybe i'm not
crazy and i don't go put a bunch of my
net worth into this or my liquid
portfolio but i probably should own a
little bit of it and that's where you're
seeing uh you know jamie dimon say that
or i'm sorry jp morgan say that uh
bitcoin has replaced gold as an
inflation hedge you're seeing bank of
america come out and say hey this entire
industry is going to explode it's not
just about the short-term issues it's
also the long-term tailwinds really
starting to create a massive change in
the economy and psychologically now
people have wrapped their heads around
like oh they're going to continue to
manipulate the economy so let's go ahead
and make sure we're positioned to
benefit from it
agreed
that's it you just agree i mean you just
went on a fire rant
dropping bombs
it's true yeah i agree i mean i was
shaking my head over here i was like
yeah yeah yeah
look at like a chicken oh okay i
complimented you and then you insulted
me no no no that was a compliment oh
chicken yeah
i'm a lion out there that is true tiger
whatever i'm a bigger dog than that a
little chicken well i don't know if a
lion's a dog but okay i'm not like dog
dog like d-a-w-g like we need more dogs
yeah we need dogs know that what what
was it coastal carolina yeah we need
more dogs little kitty cats
kitty cats we need dogs all right uh i
think we're gonna have will on here in a
few minutes uh he's not here yet
hopefully he knows before we'll come on
should we just talk about the
must thing going on let's do it go ahead
you tell us what happened elon musk is
moving their headquarters out of the san
francisco bay area in california to
austin texas that's what's going on
that's what happens when you say dumb
[ __ ] to rich people joe hit us with what
the uh pullback real quick pull up your
tweet just read us the uh the four
things that happened joe's joe's going
viral right now viral yeah go check it
out on twitter joe's going viral at the
moment he uh currently has a tweet that
is uh just out there and if you have
kids watching this show close your ears
for for five five seconds kids kids kids
don't use this language kids so lorena
gonzalez who is it an assemblywoman in
uh california
tweeted out on may 9th 2020 and just
literally just said [ __ ] elon musk not
sure why not sure what caused that
whatever but she tweeted that out so
elon musk famously said uh message
received said okay i should hear you on
that one heard
sounds good and then uh cnbc reported
along with a bunch of other people
yesterday uh on the earnings call he
finally this has been i think in the
works for a while but he said tesla's
moving its headquarters uh from
california to austin texas finally
admitted it she
obviously doubled down
and decided to attempt to dunk on him
again genius
which is obviously the right thing to do
for sure and she uh put a crying
laughing emoji and said you mean elon
musk is such a snowflake he moved from
california because i censored a bad word
about him wow isn't that weak
quite the response though the worst
thing you could do is double down that
situation i think
yeah that that is uh is probably not the
the brightest thing to do especially
considering the move was done at that
point i guess uh but elon musk right
like there's a bunch of other things
that go into this it's a year after the
initial tweet it's obviously been in the
works for a long period of time it's not
just her tweet look he's he's not an
idiot he didn't just someone talk [ __ ]
to him on the internet was like all
right i'm moving my entire business
right like a bunch of other things that
go into it but kovit had to do with it
they put a lot of uh you know
regulations and rules and simulations on
how he was able to run his business
there's obviously high taxes that are
lower in texas a bunch of workers all
this kind of there's a bunch of stuff
that goes into is my point but calling
out the world's richest person that has
a ton a ton a ton of jobs in your in
your state and is one of probably the
greatest innovators and one of the
greatest entrepreneurs of our lifetime
is a stupid stupid move just incredibly
idiotic and now she's doubling down
trying to dunk on him even further makes
no sense in my opinion and to be quite
frank like i think she deserves kind of
all the responses that she's getting uh
for doing this she's a socialist
[Laughter]
that's what it is if you condemn success
you're a socialist if you want to
redistribute wealth you're a socialist
let's just call what it is somehow in
this country we're trying to normalize
this nonsense you're a socialist if you
literally think that this is a good
thing if you celebrate when a capitalist
moves away when a capitalist takes their
job economic impact away when they take
technology and innovation away and they
move them out of your jurisdiction and
you celebrate not only are you a [ __ ]
but you're a socialist that's what you
are so okay great let's see how this
plays out if we're gonna have
politicians in certain states be
socialists and other states are gonna be
capitalist i'm not a betting man but uh
i guess i bet you we can use history as
an example of what states are going to
do better and what states aren't
remember there are so many people that
left california and new york over the
last year that they literally lost
political seats
that's how many people left hundreds of
thousands of people fled these states to
go to other places where they felt they
had more freedom so again if you want to
sit there and you want to uh go after
these folks it's become cool to bash
success it's become cool to attack them
online they're just gonna move why are
they gonna stay there why are they gonna
continue to expose themselves to your
nonsense right so congratulations yes
you can sit get their twitter retweets
you can get all the twitter likes you
want you can yell and scream with all of
your friends and say look what we made
elon musk do you know what elon musk is
saying
guess what those idiots are going to
keep doing this and more and more and
more companies are going to continue to
leave san francisco is going through
what detroit went through years and
years ago literally detroit was the
heart of capitalism it was the auto
manufacturer of the entire world
detroit went through some really tough
times san francisco is doing the exact
same thing they're making a lot of the
same exact policy mistakes
if you are abrasive to capitalism and
democracy and you continue to try to
condemn success those who create jobs
who create economic impact and who drive
innovation and job creation
they are going to leave
they have more flexibility to leave
today than ever before
and so if you keep doing nonsense
they're going to leave and that's
exactly what he did and it wouldn't
surprise me if at some point in the
future he moved spacex as well
it's going to be really hard at first to
do it because spacex has a ton of
infrastructure et cetera built down
there in la
but tesla was in palo alto hey look we
out see ya we're out of here i i think
when you uh when you start to think
about it right like the combination of
super high taxes uh
high crime in certain areas certainly in
san francisco and then shaming
entrepreneurs and shaming the people
that you want to build businesses and
bring jobs and your thing that's a
losing strategy right and we're seeing
it play out in real time literally he
took his entire business and said hey
the headquarters is moving to texas all
these new jobs we're going to create in
the future this company is going to
continue to grow continue to scale
continue to do all these things they're
all going to be in texas right so you're
losing out on not only uh kind of that
reputation that ability to attract other
people but you're losing out on tangible
things right like tax revenue and all
this other stuff so
look those are a bad combination there's
only so long that good weather can hold
out for and say hey look we're going to
attract people based on these things so
big l uh for the assemblywoman and uh
i'd be surprised if this isn't kind of
like a gut check for a lot of
politicians within california if you are
a politician or representative that
represents me as an american citizen
please do not talk [ __ ] to entrepreneurs
and innovators that are trying to help
us
it's absolutely ridiculous don't want to
see it um
i wish elon and i wish this woman much
success in what they do but i don't need
politicians and representatives kind of
going back and forth with other people
on the internet that's not how you guys
should be communicating in ways what did
they do in like and when you were like
in elementary school and stuff they went
like this like loser
she took an l she took it out
she took an l what what is what would
you do if you were uh the politician now
yeah now oh she's going to she's
well we've seen what she's done right so
she has doubled down and said more
ridiculous statements uh but now she's
quoting that elon said yeah we're going
to add 20 000 jobs or whatever over the
coming years but the whole point was the
headquarters moving right so all the
other stuff is translating out to texas
and all the future growth is going to be
going there and all this stuff so uh i
think at this point like
you're you're doing damage control right
like she's not going to she's obviously
doubling down she had a very very very
strong opinion i think her
original tweet got like 180 000 likes so
whether she thinks it was the right or
wrong thing there was some kind of like
social uh backing there so i think that
probably uh made her double down on this
and do all that uh but i don't know i
think i think it's tough she obviously
shouldn't have done it in the first
place but i think you want to reverse
course immediately as possible and be
like that's not what we intended to do
we want people like this to stay in our
community stay in our economy attract
more people this is not what we want to
represent uh and i don't know how the
hierarchy necessarily works kind of when
it comes to assemblywoman and their
social structure within the government
especially kind of related to california
and her expertise uh but if i'm higher
than her if i'm new and all this i'm
saying [ __ ] that you know what i mean
like let's figure this out like let's
let's get him back here and let's
attract other people because i think if
you uh start to see this this is one big
example but over time this stuff plays
out and it plays out really really bad
when it starts to come down on top of
each other would you apologize would you
explicitly say i'm sorry i messed up yes
john
i don't know speaks to austin though
the city elon has a quote saying there's
a limit to how big you can scale in the
bay area in austin our factory is like
five minutes from the airport 15 minutes
from downtown so another win for the
lone star state
so i say yes and i think that yeah
big win for austin but i say yes that uh
in the grand scheme of things like if
you actually look at the numbers
it's in in the grand scheme of kind of
the amount of employees and the budgets
and the taxes collected and all that
kind of stuff it's not going to make or
break california right like it's not the
end of the world it's not the biggest
thing that they're going to deal with
this year they have a billion other
things going on and this is kind of one
of those issues right so it's not going
to kill them but i think it more speaks
to your ability to realize that you were
wrong admit it and kind of move on
because
she's going to become famous for this
right like this is what she's going to
be known for is these tweets and all the
stuff just kind of how social media
works and how people uh push this stuff
out so i think ultimately if you want to
attract those type of people to your
state you have to put a stake in the
ground and say hey look i messed up i
was wrong i'm sorry and we're going to
change this because if you don't do it
people assume you still sit on that one
side of the fence you have to make sure
that everyone knows where you stand
currently otherwise you're going to
attract a bunch of other people to other
states people are going to leave people
aren't going to come in in the first
place so i think it's important to say
hey i screwed up i'm sorry and we're
going to fix this i like that thinking
the the other piece i guess is uh when
we think through how people actually uh
think about the job creation
is
is it a material increase in job
creation in texas uh is that the the
bigger focus or is it more so about like
the job creation that is lost in
california
yeah that's the thing i think uh it's
probably i'm sure texas is celebrating
right austin texas is probably pumped
that they're getting uh the recognition
for kind of growing and and being a city
that can uh attract this kind of company
so we'll see i think uh austin is
celebrating california is probably a
little upset but in the grand scheme of
things i don't think it's going to
change an entirely a large amount for
california well this was their annual
shareholder meeting right so this was
the first i believe meeting for their
annual shareholders that was actually
held from austin texas instead of being
in the san francisco bay area that's a
really big deal because he's basically
he's putting his foot in the ground
saying look if we're going to be in
texas we're going to be in texas we're
going to try to remove as quick as
possible efficiently right you don't
want to just take a loss because you're
moving your headquarters there's people
that are involved families everything
that goes into it but it's a really big
deal that people are um
are just they're losing
and when we start to think sorry someone
said no one's going to remember her name
meanwhile elon just sent four
non-astronauts to space
that seems pretty significant
the um uh the the big thing i want you
guys to talk about real quick is if you
were uh if you were elon musk right now
how would you think about uh your other
companies is it automatically gonna move
it to austin
yeah i think uh to to your point the
difficult part is that uh
oh there he goes
the difficult part is that you don't
know right i think spacex obviously has
a lot of infrastructure and boring and
all these other companies in other areas
but if elon musk is spending all of his
time there instead of commuting back and
forth you can quickly see why he would
do that from a personal level uh but i
think it comes down to how well it goes
right so maybe tesla is the first
company that does that and then he says
hey look this is working really well
we're saving a bunch of money on taxes
there's a bunch of talent moving to
austin and the surrounding areas that we
can uh kind of put ourselves into and we
can recruit these people but i think one
of the problems i read a while back was
like the lack of engineers is really bad
in that area so maybe that'll grow over
time but you have to look at kind of the
totality of these things right taxes is
one thing the quality of life is another
thing uh there's a bunch of other kind
of government things that go into it but
obviously the the ability to attract
resource and the ability to attract
talent and the locations and you need to
be close to talented schools and all
this kind of stuff is important so i
think a lot of that plays into it it's
not an easy decision
but if it works well with tesla those
are the type of things that you can
easily see compound right and he can
move his other companies he can convince
other entrepreneurs to move their
companies there and you can start to see
not only austin grow but a lot of the
other places like california san
francisco et cetera los angeles that had
all this talent start to lose it well in
texas like
for the engineering aspect of it if elon
calls you basically and is like hey you
want to be an engineer on spacex help
send people uh to space most people and
i'm saying most people because not
everyone is just gonna immediately say
yes i'll move there yeah i'll move to
texas and it's just another win for them
and eon's also he's not 60 years old
right he has started and successfully
ran multiple billion dollar company
space as tesla the boring company he was
a co-founder of paypal all these
different things and so it's a really
big deal he's going to continue to
innovate in other spaces and continue to
grow other companies and even start new
ones i want to say i don't know uh and
maybe someone in the comments can
correct me if i have this wrong or if i
have it right oh they will but i want to
say that at one point uh elon for
whatever company it was i believe it was
spacex was
was literally shuttling people from los
angeles to texas to and getting
engineers down there on a daily basis or
a weekly basis and he was basically
either putting them in hotels or flying
them back but they were literally
shuttling people and making people
commute from california to texas so uh
someone mentioned yeah there's there's
university of texas there's smu there's
rice there's a bunch of talented
universities down there with talent but
at the end of the day you need a
specific type of talent you need the
right people uh and you need people that
not only are working at the company now
to move but you need to attract new
people in san francisco are they dying
sam i mean look if if you uh
are someone who's starting a business
and you've seen a bunch of other
companies move out of that area and
there's high crime uh the politicians
are clearly showing that they do not
want certain types of entrepreneurs
there all that kind of stuff i think you
are
definitely and obviously and completely
contemplating moving your business not
only out of there but not starting one
there in the first place right like
we're moving into a world now where
the ability to attract talent is now
becoming global right your ability to
work from home your ability to connect
with people that you've never done
before not only is it cheaper in some
other area parts of the world but the
talent is better right so when you think
about it kind of on the cheap scale but
also the the quality and level of talent
that you're recruiting the ability to
open up companies
in other parts of the world has
compounded right and it's multiplied
over the last year so whether it's miami
texas uh any area right outside of the
major hubs that you would think of in
silicon valley or new york or chicago or
any of these types of areas the ability
to do that now has expanded and i think
what we're seeing is a bunch of
companies right we live in miami a bunch
of companies have moved here outside of
california new york et cetera so that
ability uh to to move your con company
to have it in a lower cost area to have
it in a lower tax area to have it in
better weather to have it closer or the
ability to rent more office space or
whatever it might be right there's a
million different reasons i think that
ability uh is going to really really
really hurt california specifically san
francisco and i think we've already seen
it well the more people that kind of
move out of their areas right so when
you're starting a business a lot of
people they would either start it in san
francisco they would start if you're in
fashion right it was new york fashion
capital of the world so you need to go
there you i need to be there i need to
be around the people that are there but
if those people move out of that city
then there's no reason to go there
anymore and it's not like your company
is just gonna make more money by being
in that city it was more about the
connections and the networking that you
had in that city and the ability to
bounce ideas off other like-minded
individuals but like you said we've gone
more and more towards a global workforce
and they can attract talent from
anywhere they can pay them less because
they live in less uh expensive cities
and it's just more more revenue for the
company and even if they pay them the
same the employee actually takes home
more by being in one of these states
will will
will i know you're watching right now i
just texted you man use the uh you use
the link that i just sent you that's my
way of communicating with woods i'm just
going to talk to you guys talk to him on
the show
what up will we we were having an issue
with the zoom real quick so i had to uh
had to go who's coming on i believe he's
going to say bitcoin's going to the moon
guys
will is on the show but we're trying to
will's watching the show we're trying to
get him on the show hit him up in the
chat say will come on man hey jack back
if you want to get out chicago miami is
beautiful you should come visit it's
amazing
we're trying to get will on we're having
some technical difficulties stick with
us real quick he's going to be on where
you at wizard
where is the wizard is the lizard
curtain
let's see if we can get him uh get him
in here and we're talking sopra today oh
sophia is the first thing the literally
the first chart is oprah guy is just
like listen we got sopra uh i don't know
what uh what is going on it says that
the host has another meeting in progress
uh which is real real weird um so i
don't know what we should uh what if we
can figure out how to get him here jordy
how are we looking and we can't get him
i don't see him
i don't see him either and it's saying
that uh he he literally sent me a a
video or like a phone like a live photo
to show that uh that it's here the host
has another meeting in progress
um i'm not really sure what is going on
so keep hitting that like button until
will gets on we need 2.5 k likes and we
are giving away a thousand dollars of
bitcoin that was like who's the guy uh
who's the announcer buffer i mean yeah
buffer for sure shoot if you want to put
me in that category fine
i don't think you sounded like buffer
ever let's get ready to rumble
yeah but seriously if we get to 2.5
000 or 2 500 likes we are giving away a
thousand dollars of bitcoin i cannot
stress this enough it is gonna help you
as an individual we're gonna pick a
winner right here live on the show today
we just need 2500 well i need you to do
two things unplug it and plug it back in
and then blow on the cartridge usually
that kind of helps with like the
nintendo 64 back in the day if you got
the red rings on the xbox you're screwed
i'm sorry man that unit's done
he's like i'm trying to get on zoom bro
what are you talking about i'm talking
about video games what are you talking
about i know we've sent i've sent will
at least six uh six different zooms
maybe that's the problem you're not very
tech savvy and uh i don't know what's
going on i'm gonna be really upset if uh
if i screwed something up here it's
gonna be real bad i mean i don't really
know uh will i just sent you another one
i just texted you another zoom link
let's see if that one works
oh my bad someone said the red rings of
death is fixable all right don't throw
your unit out will if you got the red
rings don't throw it out yet we got some
guys in the chat that can fix it joe's
not on trooms what kind of comment is
that right
that's not on shrooms all right so uh
real quick joe tell us uh about the red
rings
sure sure tell me about the red ring no
no you know about the red rings xbox
gets the red rings and everyone thinks
it's broken red rings of death they call
it all right what did you want to do but
is it not can't you fix it you can fix
it i didn't think you could back in the
day but i feel like i remember putting
like a blanket let's talk about
something else i got something so a
lottery happened this week
that a winner won 700 million dollars
would you accept this money as a
one-time payment of 400 i think it was
460 million dollars as the one-time
payment or would you take those over a
30-year span you get uh you get the 700
million that's not that's out obviously
before so the two amounts are 700 or or
like 450. i'm taking 450.
we got it we got it we got them screw
the lottery we're going right into it i
would take the 450
for sure because will's about tells why
he's going to go up
is he here i think he's on his way he's
running
well
and no i i'm not on shrooms and someone
said what's wrong with the reason
i hear him
the wizard the wizard is here all right
man what's going on
no not too much how you guys doing we're
doing awesome thank you for hanging in
there with us we got it figured out let
us just get a four let's hold the four
up to start the fourth quarter i know
yeah
all right we're gonna move through this
jeff lewis is coming on in a few minutes
but there's no way we're doing this show
without will the wizard on friday uh
telling us what's going on on chain
metrics john already brought it up sopra
first chart what's going on here
yeah last week you know we we we're
looking at this bounce when you look at
this little blue circle uh shaded circle
that i that i put in there that's what
where we were at last week and so we
were looking for do we start to get
continuation uh to the upside in the
ratio and we have in fact um as you see
on the right hand side of the chart so
um this kind of resembles if you look
back to like september of last year uh
we had this 20-plus uh
percent correction and then we came back
down re-tested that one threshold and
then uh started moving up from there so
um want to see that ideally but you know
at a minimum you want to see that one
threshold you know hold obviously and
maybe stabilize above one
but yeah i mean ideally we we continue
higher what you don't want to see
obviously is for us to go below and then
retest it and it becomes resistance but
for now looking really good
awesome
exchange supply shock ratio uh maybe not
as bullish as it's been but still not
bearish either is my read
yeah so
we have three different things here the
one that the one that's slightly bearish
is the highly liquid ratio so this is
looking at the movement of
coins from the highly liquid entities to
liquid entities so
the the ratio ticking down which means
coins are moving to the highly liquid
entities
i think you're starting to get some of
this reflecting in price um i'm actually
kind of short-term i wouldn't say like
short-term perish but
i'm a little cautious over the next two
days i think we probably come down and
like retest like 53k
um partially because of this also
exchange flows are just flat over the
last two weeks they're down like 490 btc
which
of course like isn't bearish to say it's
just not you know strongly bullish so
it's just neutral um and then like when
you look at the derivatives uh funding
um so you look at the perpetual swap
funding
we've had a really big spike over the
last like 24 hours and so to me you know
what that shows is like
traders are basically trying to trying
to leverage long the dip
and then oftentimes like when you see
funding go in the opposite direction of
price
it usually resolves in the direction of
price so like
one example would be
when we came off that failed breakdown
of 30k
um i remember uh we did it we did one of
these and i was saying that we were set
up for
favorable conditions for short squeeze
and the reason was was the same kind of
setup but the opposite so you had
funding uh going more negative as price
was going up and open interest relative
to market cap was going up so in other
words you had people piling on shorts as
price was going the opposite direction
and that resolves of course we had this
massive i remember at the time it was it
was a huge move um to like
like mid or upper upper 40ks
off those lows so
i don't think we're going to have a move
of that magnitude but i'm just saying
it's um you know when you when you start
to see that's just a good example when
you start to see funding go in the
opposite direction of price especially
as open interest is increasing as a
proportion to market cap
you're susceptible to these moves that
oftentimes resolve in the direction of
price so
i think you have some some late shorts
that hopped in and over the last 24
hours i mean you look at like some of
the aprs on on funding like i'll pull it
up right here
you know we're looking at like on some
exchanges up to like 67
apr like on buybit for example
which often times by bits wrong
while at the same time ftx is much lower
at like twenty percent um
and derivatives there was at 38 so like
overall the you know funding funding is
uh
seen a big spike over the last 24 hours
so i don't know i'm kind of short-term
cautious obviously like long-term
picture hasn't changed at all but just
to you know for hodler's like who cares
right but i'm just saying you know just
just be wary if we start to trend down
over the next couple days um come back
down and retest that 53k area
and even as low as that that retesting
that break above the point of breakdown
for may at 50k i don't think that's out
of the cards but um
i think like that 53k is probably a
logical area that's also like the
trillion dollar market cap area too so i
just think there's a couple different
things that confluence that that kind of
point to that being a nice little area
to maybe scoop up some btc over the next
couple days uh but yeah
let's skip ahead to the supply shock
ratios i saw you tweet this out earlier
this week and this chart to me seems
like one of the most important charts
right now uh in all of bitcoin where
you've got kind of the historical uh
supply shock and you've outlined in this
like green bar uh talk to me a little
bit about like what this chart is really
highlighting and then once we kind of go
through it the way that we have what
does that mean for kind of future price
movements
sure so
what you see is heading into the bull
market and the long-term guys begin to
sell into strength heading into i should
say into strength and then heading into
weakness
the long-term guys begin to accumulate
heavily so conversely the short-term
guys
increasingly hold a larger portion of
supply into strength and then they move
out of the market into weakness the
speculators all leave
and so what you see here is
we're comparing the long-term holder
supply to short-term holder supply to
get the long-term holder supply shock
ratio
and what you see is just this is
illustrating the concept that when
long-term holders lock up a certain
portion of supply then you get the
supply squeeze effect on the market
long-term holders basically set the
floor
in a macro sense and so we've actually
reached an all-time high in this metric
so if you look at the little circled
area in the top right you see where
we're at all-time highs and so what this
is showing is just
these long-term guys are locking up a
large portion of supply and you're
starting to get that effect on the
market that that supply squeeze effect
on the market um one other thing i find
interesting about this though is like
as we've talked about many times we use
a five-month threshold for this so
155-day threshold for this
when you go back five months ago well
where were we well five months ago is
may 8th right and so
that was 11 days before we had this
initial large drawdown to 30k
so to me that that's that's pretty
interesting right because you you're
you're seeing that these people are now
aging into long-term holders that held
the whole way down um and so to me that
that's that's pretty remarkable it's
it's showing that perhaps um
you know these market participants have
a have a longer term uh time horizon
got it and then let's go and look at the
bitcoin miners themselves you've got two
different charts uh one is just the
minors and then one is the minor net
position change let's start with the
minor's chart what is this showing us
and then kind of what is your view in
terms of uh what it's really telling us
yeah so the first chart with the three
different colors
orange that's hash rate and then the
blue line is difficulty and then the
green line is minor balances so what
you're seeing is that hash continues to
come back online
you know pretty aggressively and it's
come back online so aggressively that
we've had six positive difficulty
adjustments in a row which i don't even
know the last time that that's happened
it's just you know it's just another way
of kind of showing the same thing
and then also miners have started
accumulating a bit after selling into
into that rally off of the off of the
30k lows they did sell a bit um but now
they're slowly uh buying some more
nothing nothing is substantial but you
know they are now back in a positive
trend of accumulation and that's
reflected in that
minor net position change metric uh this
is just looking at the 30-day change of
minor balances so you can see we just
started creeping back into that green
area
and that that's the second chart up with
the uh you know highlighted with that
little blue circle so
yeah that that's what's going on with
miners also like
at the bottom you'll see the hash ribbon
this is another really interesting
metric um this is like probably
one of the best uh macro buy signals you
could say um in bitcoin um when you pair
this with um
when you pair this with like moving
averages for price it's been it's it's
never been wrong actually um and so what
you're trying to capture here is like
the
you're looking for these minor
capitulation events and then where hash
rate starts coming back online um and so
from first principles you're just
basically saying like for example in
2018 you have this large minor
capitulation once miners are done puking
out
their coins then you can start moving
higher
and so we've we've got this hash ribbon
buy signal about a month ago a month and
a half ago
so that that means that the 30-day
the the 30-day moving average of hash
rate is crossing the 60-day moving
average of hash rate while at the same
time the 10-day moving average of price
is crossing the 20-day moving average
price
and so yeah like
when you when you look at this um
when you go when you go from white to
light red that means that the day is
crossing the 60 day moving average when
you go from light red to red you're
going from um
you're going below and then when you go
from light red to red you're crossing
above the 60 day and then the red to
white is when the when the 30 day
crosses the 60 day to the upside and
also you have the the 10-day crossing to
20 days
so if we zoom out
what's your take middle of the bull
market still super bullish over uh kind
of the medium term kind of next 90 days
or so or has your thoughts changed
no yeah um yeah still still stand on my
thesis over the next couple months um
like i said i think perhaps we get a bit
of a pullback because some of the things
we talked about funding spiking um
exchange flows are neutral and they had
been strongly bolstered over the last
month or so so
seeing like kind of a cooling off there
um some coins becoming highly liquid and
then lastly we're actually seeing a bit
of uh selling from whales or profit
taking from wales um which i don't think
is like you know complete red flag you
know you're gonna you're gonna see these
active managers um you know uh taking
profits along the way like the when you
know when you zoom out if you wanna pull
that chart up for the audience uh i
think it's like the third or fourth
chart um
you'll see like
the the broader trend is still that
they've been an accumulation and they
they trimmed a bit too as well in in
early august so it's it's not you know
anything that um it's like a red flag
like bull market's over but i just think
perhaps we're gonna have a bit of a
drawdown to maybe like 53k um but i
don't know man like the market hasn't
been given anybody dipped so we'll see
what happens but
for those reasons um i would just say
like i'm short-term cautious not
necessarily like short-term perish but
uh long-term you know that outlook
hasn't changed so my uh my last question
for you is one of the metrics that i'm
gonna use uh to know that uh things are
getting crazy is when your friends
started asking you about bitcoin that
normally wouldn't are you still uh uh
got a lot of friends who they have no
clue what you do they're not asking
anything or has that started to happen
yet with the price going up a little bit
no not at all um not not more than usual
uh like ten some of my buddies tend to
be a bit more uh
you know nerdy like me because you know
we like geek out about stuff about like
bitcoin or whatever but um so i don't
know i
when i when i see people in general um
like people like uh that i haven't seen
in a while like everyone's always like
you know oh i see you're doing the stuff
with bitcoin like what's up with that
but um i haven't seen any like i haven't
got any like tax like oh is it a good
time to buy bitcoin or anything like
that
i think like this stuff too is reflected
in
like google search trends um i think the
block has some good like retail related
data um so you look at google search
trends also like um coinbase app
downloads is another way to look at it
um also you can look at the large
twitter accounts
um the large youtube accounts like some
of these things but the google search
trends is is primarily i think that and
the coinbase app downloads are probably
two of the better metrics for that and
those are both still way down
and then also you look at like
you can separate volume into you say
okay you know
what size transactions are dominating
excuse me or dominating volumes on each
given day
and so what you see is over the last
month and a half really large
transactions have completely dominated
volume like we're talking like 10
million plus transactions have gotten up
to like 80 percent of all the volume on
any given day over the last month and a
half so that's just another way to look
at right now the the institutional
capital i think the smarter money you
could say i think is is uh more so in
the market and i don't think we've seen
uh retail come in full force yet awesome
all right we got a whole bunch of [ __ ]
we still got to go through on the show
will you're a legend will the wizard
please if you haven't already go follow
him on twitter what you cross over 300
000 followers now on his way to a
million uh oh no we'll pass me yeah
[Music]
well
congratulations will and all your
success so far
appreciate man congrats
hey that that's the real flipping
congrats man that's awesome awesome
appreciate you guys all right we'll talk
soon all right thanks so much all right
see you guys
all right
he's got jokes too that's the real
flipper he just passed me man joe you
you're struggling huh
i mean
i need to be tweeting out fire like will
and then i'll gain more followers
yeah the guy tweets out fire he puts in
the work he's a good guy will's beast
listen uh it's not the wizard
he deserves it it's not my uh not my
fault that you can celebrate success
around here we do celebrate yeah he
deserves it for sure he's gonna end the
year with a hell of a lot more too what
was your guess 500 john i guess like 300
350.
350. he's gonna go over 500 i think now
watching over the last like three weeks
and bitcoin was like you know it went up
a little bit but not like we haven't hit
that whoo he's gonna go what do you
think you win the you're right
not 500 recording in progress
i mean what would have to happen in like
the sports business world for that to
happen i'm gonna start tweeting about
i'm gonna tweet about bitcoin only
exclusively bitcoin when bitcoin goes up
i'm a will you got competition now you
were doing like 54 you were tweeting out
54k 55k 56k i'm gonna be doing the exact
same thing y'all follow me for updates
on bitcoin
all right i'm changing my mind we're
done with bitcoin we're done with
bitcoin we gotta talk about joe pomplia
i think we have jeff here with us uh
jeff are you there
hey what's up how are you
doing well how about you i'm doing
fantastic uh we've got a whole bunch of
stuff to talk about first i want to uh
uh just tell everyone a little bit about
jeff jeff is uh i joke but not really
that he's one of the last independent
thinkers available on the internet
you're not following jeff on twitter
you're missing out so please go follow
him but jeff you recently moved to
austin maybe we'll start there
what was the thought process between uh
leaving um and then moving to austin
versus anywhere else
yeah i mean i didn't really leave i
didn't really leave anywhere so you know
i sort of travel around i go places i
was living uh living on kauai for uh for
several months prior to moving here and
the debate was really around going back
to sort of a major city so you know i'd
split my time i think you and i pomp met
in new york i sort of slipped my time
between sf which is just a at this point
a total [ __ ] city so i could never
go back there in new york which i i
think is still probably pretty good
debate was between returning to one of
those or trying something different
and then spending uh so much time uh you
know on the beach on kauai like out on
the water i really realized that i
actually get a lot of energy from just
having a lot of empty space around me i
always thought i was a city person and
wanted to be in a crowded city but i
love having space and so i think it's a
question for me of what gives you energy
for me i get a lot of energy from having
space space to think austin has this
very frontier feel to it a lot of
independent thinkers are moving here
maybe i'm maybe very kind of you to say
i'm one of the few that are are still
available on the internet they're
actually i think they're quite a few and
a lot of them are here in austin so a
lot of space and a lot of interesting
header docs thinkers and it so far it's
been pretty good it's been a few months
and uh uh you know planning to stay
talk to us about bedrock you've got one
of the the more interesting portfolios
because a lot of the companies are
companies that either other venture
capitalists don't find interesting don't
find valuable they don't have the
courage and conviction to invest in a
whole bunch of different stuff but what
is the investment thesis of bedrock when
you when you talk to investors or
founders
i mean our whole like guiding ethos is
we are truly trying to find what we call
these narrative violations so these
companies that are either you know
undiscovered or underestimated because
they run contra to a popular narrative
and so this really animates a lot of the
stuff we've done everything from our
early investing in cryptocurrencies we
were first getting started with the firm
obviously you talked a lot about bitcoin
and ethereum and things like that
to the companies that we invest in
things like flock safety we're one of
the largest investors one of the
earliest investors that's a company that
uses uh computer vision uh sort of crime
solving cameras to help help
municipalities solve crime and when we
initially invested in flock for example
uh back in 2018 uh no one was talking
about there being sort of a major crime
problem in the united states like no one
thought it was a problem that needed to
be solved moreover that was a company
that monetizes while it monetizes
through like a sas subscription other is
a hardware component and pelletin you
know was was not a huge public company
uh people were scared to invest in
hardware but we both thought that crime
was a huge problem that you could have
these hardware businesses that monetize
through sas and those could actually be
very valuable and you know fast forward
to 2021 flock's valued at i don't think
i should disclose it but many multiples
of where we initially invested we've
continued to to back up the truck into
it as it's as it scaled and the murder
rate unfortunately this is you know
really bad for society we wish it wasn't
the case but it increased by 30 in 2020
that is the largest single year increase
in u.s history largest single year
increase in the murder rate in u.s
history and flock is kind of an anecdote
uh to this uh antidote to this uh to
this to this issue and so we try to find
these counter narrative companies a lot
of it actually comes down to feeling a
vibe with a certain entrepreneur with a
certain company mission and then really
peeling back the layers uh really
digging into the business over over
quite a long period of time before we
invest so it's it's it runs pretty
contra to sort of the way that venture
capital is as being done today where you
sort of you know you meet someone on
zoom for 20 minutes then wyoming 100
million dollars the next day
when you think about defense and public
safety you just talked about one of the
companies but it seems like that maybe
it hasn't become taboo but there's a
bunch of people in what i'll just label
as silicon valley it's not
geographically contained just there but
the tech industry more in general for
some reason it's become like not an
important thing or even in some cases
they've actually tried to shun working
on the defense industry or with public
safety law enforcement etc uh talk a
little bit about like do you have a
thesis there uh is it something that
again just literally you meet the
founders you like the mission and you
back them how do you think about it
yeah i mean the the way that we think
about uh defense broadly is um is you
know there's there's sort of this
fundamental belief that i think we have
as a team which is we're actually uh you
know quite pessimistic generally about
the world and so we're not sort of these
uh uh these bright-eyed optimists about
the future we actually are relatively
pessimistic uh sort of um broadly
broadly speaking but i think we're like
quite um quite specifically optimistic
so we think there are these sort of
specific uh things people can do there
are specific companies there are
specific places perhaps so places like
austin are where you live pomp and miami
we're sort of optimistic about these
optimistic about these places and and
sort of the we think the cleanest
manifestation of this sort of
generalized pessimism specific optimism
is is sort of there's a lot we can do in
defense and it's obviously existential
for the us as a country we have to imbue
our our defense industry with with real
technology we have there's been this
insane uh sort of cartel of uh of
defense contractors and uh and primes
that have sort of controlled the defense
industry uh for you know half a half a
century and we have to bring silicon
valley valley prowess engineering
state-of-the-art technology into into
that area so we're very you know proud
to be investors in companies like anderl
uh like apparent uh like uh modern
intelligence all of which are taking
different cuts at china uh trying to
really uh imbue the defense industry
with silicon valley style innovation
quite honestly flock on a sort of more
municipal civic level uh we view is also
a manifestation of this uh of this
defense theme and then the hesitance of
silicon valley investors and and
entrepreneurs and engineers to work in
defense i think i think they're becoming
a lot less hesitant so i think that
there was sort of maybe this uh
i think maybe the sort of pandemic and
2020 kind of woke people up to the fact
that
you can't sort of just slide into this
like nihilistic zone where nothing
really matters and you know you should
just be uh you know uh sort of uh coding
uh making the google page rank algorithm
a better or something something stupid
like that like actually you have one
life there are things that matter there
are things that that that you can do as
a as an engineer as an entrepreneur and
one of the most important areas to work
and we believe is is in defense
technology so we're really excited to
have done a fair amount there yeah and
some of the companies you named are
absolutely amazing companies with really
kind of breakthrough technologies uh
talk to me about uh what when i think of
you vibe capitalists so most people uh
look at venture capitalists they have a
specific kind of framework in their head
or or some generalizations
you have pioneered and popularized the
idea of a vibe capitalist
when you were uh in hawaii there were
shirtless photos there was uh
videos with your glasses on i think at
one point you were even showing people
how to use the forehead temperature uh
kind of reader and i think people just
found it very refreshing right you were
literally talking about serious topics
obviously uh you've got kind of this
expertise and experience and uh
technology and investing but you did it
in a different way so what exactly is a
vibe capitalist and like where did this
come from
yeah absolutely well we're gonna be
bringing the videos back we're getting
the custom thermometer made right now
and building up the studio here in
austin so attempt check with jeff will
be we'll be back soon uh and thanks for
those kind words you know this whole
idea of a vibe capitalism sort of an
outgrowth of where i think we're at in
this technology uh this incredible this
this phenomenal technological uh cycle
that we've we've been in really since i
got into the industry and really
initially as an entrepreneur in 2009 now
as an investor i started doing investing
in 2012. and really we've gotten to a
point where um you know algorithms
really mediate so many of our
interactions as humans they mediate how
we work with each other uh so if you're
scaling up a company today chances are
you know you've probably never met in
person are the employees you're hiring
if you're running sort of a remote or
hybrid company today that's just crazy
to imagine 10 years ago hiring hundreds
of employees a day these folks are never
meeting the teams they work with it
makes us a lot more efficient you know
you can communicate really efficiently
via slack we're doing this via zoom so
algorithms really do optimize for
efficiency and efficiency is not a bad
thing efficiency is actually i believe a
very good thing but efficiency is not an
end goal in and of itself and i feel
like we are in a zone societally because
of all this technology we have enabling
us where it's it's sort of easy to
mistake uh efficiency for sort of an
enabling tool to help you live a better
life to help enrich your humanity for
efficiency being an end goal in and of
itself and this is you know why i sort
of i don't really like investing in
productivity tools because i feel that
sort of you know the anti-vive type
company it's all about just efficiency
is the end goal where there are these
other types of businesses and companies
where the algorithmic agenda is in
service to a bigger mission is in
service to an end goal and so sort of
there's not really a a wide capital
framework but there is a vibe capital
filter and i'd say that the the vibe
capital filter you know we're still
working on figuring it figuring it out
i'm going to be giving a given a keynote
speech at web summit in lisbon on
november 2nd where we're going to go
through this framework in depth but it's
some version of filtering companies
filtering your own personal life
actually through a filter of is the
algorithmic agenda of the the algorithms
that you're engaging with is it serving
your own personal agency or is it
synonymous with your own personal agency
are they the same or is the algorithmic
agenda serving you and so for you pomp
you're a vibe capitalist man like you
are you've mastered the algorithms
they're serving you they're serving pomp
you're not you're not what you're doing
is not synonymous with uh with the
twitter algorithm or the youtube
algorithm you're using those to serve
your own agency you know the company
version of this would be
uh does the algorithmic agenda serve a
company or you know if we're talking
about the decentralized world web three
a protocols mission uh does it really
work which is also you know a reflection
of the entrepreneur's mission or is it
synonymous with the mission so you can
think about something like bitcoin uh
the mission with satoshi is all around
shifting economic control and power into
the hands of individuals and communities
contrast that versus something like uh
so that's a vibe bitcoin's a vibe okay
that's a vibe capitalist uh type thing
to be involved in i would argue that
something like shiba inu is not uh shiba
inu is not it's just derivative of
dogecoin so you know there's some
version of this where shiva is like an
efficiency thing even though it seems
like a seems like a joke it's kind of
you know to dogecoin what lazy line is
to board ape or something like that so
more derivative you know a company
example would be something like newbank
where i was a very early investor on
behalf of a venture capital firm that i
used to be a partner at prior to
founding bedrock where their mission
statement and they live this they've
lived this from the first day i met that
company in 2015 it's to imagine a
different world it starts off with you
know imagine a different world where
what matters is your values not the
value in your bank account so like yeah
they're they're in neo bank they started
out issuing credit cards and writing
algorithms around that but their mission
is like very different from what those
algorithms are actually doing that is
vibe capitalism versus something like uh
versus something like google where their
mission starts out with organize the
world's information that's exactly what
the algorithms do they give you the most
efficient search experience they give
the advertisers the most efficient way
to reach people uh google is all about
efficiency it is not a vibe company and
so we sort of have this filter around uh
algorithmic agendas and efficiency that
we uh that we use and uh and you know
there's a level on which uh it it layers
up to the people running the companies
so think about think about travis
running uber versus dara running uber
you know i was on the board of lyft for
many years well i hated competing
against travis that guy has a vibe dara
you know not so much steve jobs versus
scully and it can also go the other
direction so um you know think about
twitter when dick costello was uh or
costello was ceo sort of this um you
know kind of like a failed comedian or
something like that and and one might
one might think he has a vibe but i
would argue that jack dorsey has a has
much more of a vibe and and so we sort
of think about things on all these
levels and try to optimize more and more
in a vibe direction
as you already know i love this
framework and uh it's one of those
things where i think like once you start
to understand it you see the examples
it's very easy to identify uh if you're
looking for it but it also requires
something that you've talked a lot about
is like being outside of the information
flow so uh maybe tell us a little bit
you went on a trip recently and you
tweeted out you were like hey i didn't
talk to anybody and then all of a sudden
i came back and like everything is doing
well like maybe the best thing an
investor can do sometimes is not do
anything or remain outside of that flow
of information because it allows them to
kind of think differently so talk a
little bit kind of how you're you're
thinking about at least right now
yeah i mean one of the challenges as uh
as uh one gets sort of more successful
and you know we've scaled bedrock pretty
rapidly match about a billion dollars
now sort of less than four years old is
that you get pulled into all of these
information flows people want to share
things with you and actually all of the
best investing i've done was i was sort
of an outsider
reaching out to an entrepreneur
discovering something that other people
weren't looking at i wasn't in the
mainstream silicon valley a flow of
information and uh and i think it's been
sort of this uh this very uh this very
valuable thing for for me i think at
bedrock you know we we don't try we
don't want to be totally outside the
information flow so you know
sort of need people to to know what's
going on you know i've got great
partners and eric and spencer bedrock
where we sort of are are keyed in a bit
to what's happening but i try and spend
real chunks of time you know outside of
the flow and and more specifically i do
feel like there are these phases of
cycles where things just get so frenzied
that the decision-making can be uh can
get sort of very sloppy you can end up
making sort of very manic investment
decisions and i felt this way in you
know q4 2017 we were we were trying to
kick off our fundraise for bedrock you
had the crazy run-up in in bitcoin and
the crazy ico craze and i really sat
that stage of the cycle out i didn't
really do any ico investing i was just
sat out it felt too frenzied you know
one might argue that maybe the sort of
growth stage uh late stage venture
capital markets today maybe even the the
public markets in some of these areas
are maybe just a little bit too frenzied
so i tried to sort of take part of the
summer to really just take a vacation
from investing and you know i think i
made more money this summer that i've
made in a really long time so sometimes
you just
you can just sort of do nothing if
you've got the right portfolio in place
and try and check out when things feel
when things feel very frenzied i don't
think you want to feel pressured to
participate in a frenzy because everyone
else is doing it uh that's sort of the
opposite of uh of operating with
personal agency that's sort of getting
pulled in by the algorithmic agendas uh
whether it's on on robinhood or uh or
twitter or anything like that
into a friends you always want to try
and avoid that the extent you can yeah i
tend to think that that's right uh you
also have talked about this idea of
iconic companies vibing with
iconoclastic investors what does that
mean
well uh you know you also be careful
using the word iconoclast because
historically as i've sort of used it but
historically uh it just means tearing
down there's no building up element so
if you're just a pure icono class you're
sort of ripping things down but you're
not creating anything to uh to
to replace them but the way that i use
that phrase iconoclastic founders
iconoclastic investors is you know vibe
is something intangible it's a feeling
it's just something that you sense you
feel you vibe with someone and the words
really i think been cheapened this idea
of vibe because it's sort of become a
meme you know i started using it now
everyone's tweeting about it but it
actually means something profoundly
human that can't be captured by an
algorithm and uh and and i do think
there is just this sense in which there
are very few investors out there i think
you're one of them i can think of maybe
a dozen more very few folks investing in
technology that have a public presence
that are digitally engaged that are
sharing their thinking that have a real
vibe that are iconoclastic that believe
in in things that are trying to seek out
truth versus just uh versus just sort of
doing what's uh what's popular getting
the most engagement and i feel like
there's a you know set of entrepreneurs
doing the most interesting things that
vibe with that set of investors and so
sort of just being true to yourself and
trying to seek out truth and being
courageous in the world there's a lot of
value one can one can uh you know
generate or unlock or or partake in
through through just being a little bit
iconoclastic but the caveat to this is
you have to actually uh you have to
actually be trying to build things to
you can't just tear institutions down as
as broken as the old institutions are so
uh completely unrelated yet somewhat
related uh you went on a tear i came
remember it was the end of last year
beginning of this year
with the midas list which for those that
don't know is the forbes list of uh most
successful investors uh in a given year
and uh everyone i think pretty much
knows like how they count can be uh kind
of subjective and and uh if you don't
fit in the box then that it doesn't
count to some degree but walk us through
uh your midas list uh locking of the
horns and are you submitting are you
gonna give them your returns
i don't submit i'm too legit to submit
so no i will i will not be uh i will not
be submitting to the midas list i've
i've i i did it when i was much more
insecure and earlier in my career uh you
know i submitted i think two or three
years to the list the numbers it's all
completely subjective so it's it
actually falls into this category of
what i call these faux quantitative type
type things and you know one could argue
one of the really common metrics and uh
when you invest in in private technology
companies is nps net promoter score
that's like a faux quantifiable um esg
environmental social good it's kind of a
faux quantifiable you create these sort
of fake metrics but really it's sort of
the subjective subjective type thing
you're trying to quantify something
that's fundamentally qualitative and the
midas list serve is a different cut on
this where they they ask the vcs to
submit so you can go to submit
midasdata.com there's an actual website
you can check out entrepreneurs should
really check that website out i'd really
encourage founders to go look at submit
midasdata.com see what data the midas is
actually connecting on collecting on
your businesses all because these
venture capitalists want to be ranked on
this list and at the end of the day all
of that data it's really just
information gathering for the list
keepers for the for the list keepers and
in fact they rank things ultimately it's
it's uh there's subjective judgment that
that actually drives the ultimate
ranking and they even admit that in the
in the asterisks on the submit certified
as data site so you know you always have
to disclose your biases one of my one of
my mentors i have a lot of respect for
us is praying about phrase sorry where
like it's it's okay to have uh biases
but you've got to disclose them and you
know my bias is i'm very strongly biased
against the midas list because uh i
should have been on it uh i should have
been on it uh many times and uh they're
they're biased against me and then at
the end of the day uh i'm just too legit
to submit so uh you know the vcs can
keep uh fighting over uh fighting over
their ranking on the modest list i'm
busy generating vibes over here and uh
we'll let up we'll let you know we'll
see you know what happened to old king
midas was he uh his lust for gold uh led
to his death and we'll sort of see what
happens to midas list i just created the
pomp list and i just put you as number
one so my subjective list has you uh at
the top
oh yeah okay now we're vibing now
uh i got one more question that i got my
brothers here they got a couple
questions for you but uh there's this
framework [ __ ] you money versus ignore
you money what's the difference
you know i i
look the i'm i i sort of try to have a
positive energy so i'm you know i'm sort
of pessimistic about about a lot of
things with with the future i try and
focus on on the good and you know it's
it just doesn't really feel worth to me
in life like trying to really [ __ ]
someone over like there are there are
these hyper successful people where it's
like okay now that i have this level of
wealth i can just use this to [ __ ] this
person over i'm just gonna [ __ ] them and
that's not really ever been a motivating
thing for me i kind of feel like free at
this point where it's like i don't have
to worry about like [ __ ] other people
over i can live my life i can work with
people i i really care about at bedrock
and with the companies that we invest in
um if someone has wronged me and trust
me many many people have wronged me over
the years there's a very long list of
people that have that have wronged me
but uh but i just choose to ignore them
i don't really want to [ __ ] with anyone
and i i feel like orienting around this
[ __ ] you money concept is actually quite
unhealthy is is actually maybe
borderline it's not nihilistic at least
you believe in [ __ ] people over but
there's definitely something
somewhat unhealthy about that being sort
of the animating factor for you once
you've made it
joe john what questions do you guys have
yeah uh jeff thanks for doing this first
off your chain is giving off good vibes
i like that right there uh it's like
five dollars i think got it seven eleven
or something but i'm you know
trying to not look like a boomer or
something like that
i respect it even better than it was
cheaper uh so what's going on in san
francisco you used to live there for for
a decade you've obviously moved to
austin what are the problems they're
facing and how do you think that impacts
kind of the companies you're investing
in
man well there's a whole litany of
problems i'm definitely not an expert on
it i haven't lived there uh if the
california ftb the tax the tax
collection agency i've not lived in
california since 2017 so i'm i'm really
not not positioned to to comment comment
too much on san francisco today but
certainly uh they've screwed up all of
the key things so it's been uh crime you
still need a relatively safe city so
that's sort of this completely uh out of
control uh d.a in in chessa who has just
completely destroyed things from a crime
standpoint uh you've got the homeless
issue which san francisco had you know
the wealthiest city really in the world
has the most income inequality the most
wealth inequality in the united states
that city's had decades to solve the
homelessness problem they sort of
haven't been able to tackle it they've
alienated the tech entrepreneurs the
people who really brought the prosperity
to the region and there is sort of this
mass exodus type thing going on i really
hope it can get fixed the challenge i
think at a sort of very nuanced level is
you have a very powerful um board of
supervisors actually this is a challenge
in austin where i live now as well where
you've got a weak mayor and sort of all
of these uh all these uh supervisors
where it's very hard to really get
anything done and so i think there's a
sense in which if you're a city you sort
of want a government structure it's
quite easy to get things done quite easy
to make changes make decisions and san
francisco has an opposite extreme
opposite version of this where it's
almost impossible uh to get things done
because the way that board of
supervisors works and there's a
lightweight version of this in austin
although i think things are in much much
much better shape here but um
i am yeah really bearish on sf i think
silicon valley will still remain the
epicenter so you know one of the things
that's
uh you know good about silicon valley is
there's lots of boring places outside of
san francisco
that are very different you could live
in the east bay you could live in the
south bay and i think a lot of folks you
know will just continue to choose to do
that there's a version of that in austin
it's it's somewhat more boring than
miami uh which for me is a feature not a
bug but you know different strokes for
different folks
john what questions you got yeah thanks
jeff for doing this really appreciate it
it's nice to meet you bitcoin it's
definitely a vibe
i'm gonna have to agree on that one 100
100 yeah
i'm curious if and when the
bitcoin protocol becomes the norm what
companies and uh different i guess
features are you excited to see being
built
yeah i mean look i think the i think i
think bitcoin right now to me i still
buy into the store value narrative there
i feel like maybe ethereum is becoming
the programmable money type type thing
and then i really am uh intrigued by uh
by by nfts and and uh you know some of
these other you know i think salon is
very interesting i'm trying to wrap my
head more around nfts and and get an
understanding there but i i really do
just believe that uh there's such a high
volume when i think about all the most
you know talented interesting like
people with unique uh sort of
one-of-a-kind vibes a lot of those
people are going into this world into
this universe and i i definitely think
it's here to stay in some form we
obviously have a sort of existential
risk with the governments but i i do
think it's it's here to stay in some
form and and i'm i'm excited about the
whole ecosystem i do feel like i've been
not as engaged really as i should have
been you know back in
back in 2014 i spoke at coin summit
london i was sort of early to this whole
world and i i remember that conference
very well uh and i i sort of just ended
up buying some of these things and
holding them and ever you know i've sort
of sold along the way every time i've
sold i've regretted it and so i'm
working right now my mission for 2022 is
actually just get much more engaged on
this entire universe and you know i
think there are things more off the
radar like radar like like urban that
are that are worth exploring and and
worth really digging into but there's a
a ton of creative energy and a lot of
excitement on my end around around this
whole area
jeff one of my questions for you is uh
what's your normal day look like like in
terms of you you've got a couple of
different things going on but you also
try to see outside that flow of
information you kind of uh take this
different approach
what do you do during the day and like
what does that kind of schedule look
like
well the crime span is as as uh as
little time as possible on zoom so this
is an exception to my rule so i'm hardly
ever on zoom i do a lot of uh running
walking uh hiking climbing so i like to
be outside i like to be active i like to
be physical and then just meeting with
smart interesting people like in person
so if i have to hop on a plane to meet
with someone i'll do that i love you
know people come visit me but i spend a
lot of time meeting with people that's
one of the great joys of sort of this
this stage of sort of the pandemics a
little bit less acute right now and uh
and so it's meeting different people
trying not to have a schedule the sort
of basic routines i want to sort of eat
at the same time every day i want to try
and work out at the same time every day
you want to carve out time for
independent thinking there are obviously
basic things you have to do in terms of
like you know there's board meetings
there are things like that that you've
got to do but i try and schedule those
in pre-defined blocks and then leave
them as much unstructured time as
possible up for thinking for activity
for being you know healthful and mindful
as possible and not get pulled in you
know again back to vibe not get pulled
into letting an algorithmic agenda you
know whatever the algorithm is uh
dictate on my agenda for the day i'm
sort of always trying to avoid that very
consciously
got it where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about bedrock
jeff lewis oregon twitter and it's spelt
gioff geo ff lewis org and you can check
out our website bedrockcap.com
thanks so much all right well hold on
i'm not letting you leave i got one more
question what's your
what's your pitch to founders if
founders are building a business why uh
why should they work with you or what do
they get out of it what's kind of when
you sit down the founder what's the
bedrock pitch well the best sales people
never sell so i can't disclose that on
the on the
stream
that's the best pitch possible all right
bedrock cap.com
uh is what you said
that's right
b-e-d-r-o-c-k like make the bedrock
cap.cap.com all right bedrock cap.com or
jeff lewis org uh jeff the people in the
comments are asking how much you're
benching these days
i'm like i'm i'm like i'm a little bit
yolked right now i haven't i haven't
been hitting the gym as much as i
usually do i've been more focused on
cardio so i'm a bit emaciated but we'll
do some more shirtless stuff soon
walking program
i i got it wait hold on because i got
you on here i got to say this the very
first one that he put up uh with the the
temp check but i don't think you were
calling it temp check at first i think
it was just a video that he did he was
in hawaii and everyone was like
what the [ __ ] is going on where is he
and then of course i talked to him he's
like oh i'm in hawaii and i was like are
you gonna keep doing them and he was
like yeah of course and then the next
one was like you on like a rock
somewhere in like nature and i was like
this is gonna get crazy real fast and
there's gonna be some people who love it
and some people who absolutely hate it
that's exactly what happened so i love
it i think you should keep doing it
it's coming back so it's coming back
game on thanks for the support awesome
man all right thanks so much for doing
this we'll talk soon thanks jeff see you
later thanks everyone bye
dude that was all time
he is hilarious he's uh he's also like
super super super smart which is makes
it even funnier than he's yeah he's one
of the top investors in the world yeah
that's great yeah and he talks about
vibe checks about the founders he was
voted top 100 venture capitalists in the
world in 2019 2019 he should have been
on the list for years before that that's
why he was mad yeah yeah crazy worked at
the founders fund but by the way uh one
of the most all-time tweets ever like
one of the biggest flexes of all time
let me see if i can find it real quick
uh was david sacks during this whole uh
this whole debacle about it um
david sacks tweeted something and uh was
basically talking about the fact that uh
you can only get onto the um midas list
if you meet their criteria
but hey let me see if i can quickly find
this this this is so that i don't know
what is the midas list he said it
earlier it's it's a collection of the
best investors based on returns but you
submit the data and it's like yeah you
submit it and a lot of times what they
require is uh for you to put the money
of your actual companies
that's the problem i can't find i can't
find the exact tweet but basically what
he said was he said uh i've invested in
like 25 different unicorns i've seen
invested in 25 unicorns but uh i doesn't
count for the midas because it was all
personal money yeah
oh yeah here we go that should boost you
up on the list
what is it joe no i got i got this right
here uh
so someone tweeted oh jeff tweeted yeah
yeah that's why that's what i brought
yeah so jeff tweeted he goes uh well
keith roboy will likely be on the midas
list this year uh he hasn't been the
fact that he hasn't been it on the past
two to three years minimum speaks
volumes that it's about his methodology
and then david sacks responded to that
tweet and goes i had a pretty good year
too eight exits talenteer airbnb wish
affirm open door porch postmates send
wave but none of them count because it
was my own money so i keep a hundred
percent instead of twenty percent which
midas doesn't likes whatever
that's a pretty good list of companies i
had eight exits but it was my own money
mine's done like that
that's all unbelievable right yeah
that's great whatever by the way they're
doing the best they can too but uh if
you're a if you're a vibe capitalist you
you don't submit to too legit to submit
that was an all time line
i feel like if you guys went to austin
to hang out with jeff you'd come back
and be like dude we love jeff yeah i
come back
like it's a vibe out there he said i'm
doing a little too much cardio right now
it's not as small as i normally
all right we got a problem what i only
have 99.9k i don't think we're going to
get there
we're trying to give you a thousand
dollars yeah that's true you know what
i'll do though
i'll uh
i'll meet you guys halfway
on the count of three if you press the
like button we cross over 2k i'll give
out 500 how about that wow that's fair
right damn you nice guy one two three
press the like button right now like it
and we're going to give us a thumbs up
we're gonna pick one person
i'm gonna get 500
of bitcoin
let's go are we there let's take it so
long why it's taking so long to get to
2k
what are you guys looking at oh just
we're just making sure the chats with
the vibe yeah yeah vibe
you know we should do maybe we should uh
fix the um
uh
the little set design here maybe we need
like a new set design with what vibes
like vibe check vibe meter temp check
yeah like do like a little we're gonna
have to license that from jeff the temp
check i'm not temp champion temp
check but we're gonna be vibing sure all
right we hit two point if we hit 2k all
right
here's what i want everyone here's what
i want
[Music]
i gotta put the camera on me got him you
guys you guys see this listen do you see
this awesome shirt right here
this has got the bowl with the laser
eyes right you can go the bestbusiness
show.com and get that i'm rocking the
classic merch today just real quick you
see this hat right here bitcoin 100k
you can go ahead and you can buy this at
thebestbusinessshow.com
but let me show you again real quick
right that shirt is now
uh jordy put the camera on uh joe and
john real quick what's up what's up do
you do you see we got the classic
yeah that's the hands team all right
joey put the camera ahead
he ain't got no hands y'all see that all
right what are we doing one of them what
are we doing for the giveaway
you guys better be careful we're vibing
no your vibes are real low right now you
just threw stuff out bro right you got
sandals on with no socks or shoes no
that's usually how i like to wear saints
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go
someone's about to catch a 500 vibe real
quick
what i want to know
is if you win the 500 bucks what are you
gonna do
let's go drop it drop it in the chat
right now what are you gonna do with the
500 if we give it to you joey sticky
hands that's what they're called
that guy catches everything
throw some more stuff i don't know if
that's why they call you sticky hands
i'm not stealing [ __ ] so why else would
they call me
[Laughter]
joe since you got so many thoughts right
now someone pick somebody yeah let's go
okay uh dan howe
wow good you didn't even look boom boom
quick on the trigger how did you come up
with the name you're doing with it
uh he said he's buying bitcoin i think
dan bro you don't even know
h-o-w-e
dan h-o-w-e h-o-w-e yeah dan howe by my
kids bitcoin is what he said oh there
you go
see i don't even have to look i got an
eye dan dan howe drop your twitter
account before we get out of here
let's go dan howe drop it right now dan
cause i'm not chasing you down
dan how where are your kids are gonna be
rich where are ya dan how five hundred
dollars of bitcoin right there four for
there he is john there he is
blitzer is that blitzer
blitzer six one three
i mean have you got the damn damn me on
twitter too
if you could
blitzer613 all right
what do we get we got the nfl we got the
ticket guy we got the ticket guy but
like i said he didn't realize that it
was in dallas this weekend so now we can
we're going to we're going he's going to
new york he's going to go in two games
you know when they're back home almost
like gonna see saguan put up some yachts
i think i'll be at that game too oh john
oh maybe a little meet and greet with
johnny maybe maybe
you got a little beer will call right
here
johnny will call
saquon right now stat prediction for the
uh for dallas yeah against dallas
dallas good team good team
100 total yards though i'll take the
over north of that for sure one one
teddy
i think saquon's going to have
145 yards oh wait whoa big game yeah 120
yards rushing 25 yards receiving two
touchdowns and
a passing touchdown
oh
i don't know if he's got one of those in
his career yet
hey i'm just saying hey career game for
sake hey coach coach let him warm up let
the guy warm up all right anything else
got tony on the jet sweep no no no no no
jet sweep for cadarius tony listen i
like cadarius tony but we ain't going
with the gym
last time they did that
for watching
i appreciate it
all right the vibes were good today i
had a great time how about you guys had
a great time happy friday everyone pay
off your credit card i hope everyone has
an incredible incredible weekend we
appreciate all of you guys tuning in
every single day sorry dan how 500 bucks
richer thanks for watching the show
sorry we get a little crazy sorry things
go off the rails it's all good life is
good life is good vibes are good
it's fine vibe checks off the chart
yeah
all right
later